[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el 3 de mayo
se celebran 30 años de la declaración de
windhoek para el desarrollo de una
prensa libre independiente y pluralista
que dio origen a la conmemoración de
este día por la libertad de prensa está
con nosotros guillerme canela jefe del
área de libertad de prensa y también
seguridad de periodistas de la unesco
desde wing namibia gracias por estar con
nosotros señor canela buen día y
bienvenido a france 24 él le preguntó
por qué es tan importante la relación de
winehouse que dio origen a hace 30 años
desde áfrica a la celebración del día de
la libertad de prensa en el mundo
hola muy buenos días a ustedes un placer
hablar con ustedes desde bildu que tiene
todo este simbolismo para la protección
y promoción de la libertad de expresión
es de la libertad de prensa como apenas
señalaste hace 30 años un conjunto muy
significativo de periodistas y de otros
actores estuvieron acá en windhoek para
celebrar tres elementos centrales de la
idea de una prensa de una prensa que
contribuya para la democracia para los
derechos humanos y para el desarrollo
sostenible que esta prensa tiene que ser
libre tiene que ser independiente y
tiene que ser plural desde entonces cada
día 3 de mayo lo que hacemos es mirar
distintos ángulos del sistema de
desarrollo mediático para hacer con que
esas tres cosas puedan ser alcanzadas de
nuevo independencia en libertad y
pluralidad para los medios que es
fundamental para proteger otros derechos
humanos
guillerme la unesco lanzó el lunes una
discusión global sobre la transparencia
de los gigantes de internet es necesaria
una mayor regulación para enfrentar las
técnicas y el discurso de odio
este el tema de este año justamente 30
años después de vinto que el tema del
día mundial de la libertad de prensa
este año es información como un bien
público información como un bien común
y para que tengamos esta información
como un bien común como un bien público
un conjunto de políticas públicas son
necesarias entre ellas la idea de
transparencia de las empresas de
internet porque transparencia porque
para efectivamente combatir con
evidencias fenómenos como éste es que
usted apenas mencionó desinformación
discurso del odio teorías de la
conspiración etcétera nosotros
necesitamos entender mejor nosotros
todos nosotros algunas cuestiones clave
como los datos que circulan sobre
desinformación o sobre discursos del
odio que exactamente las compañías de
internet hacen para combatir estos
procesos cuando hacen la la curación de
contenidos o la moderación de contenidos
entonces la unesco quiere lanzar un
debate global que va a ser este próximo
lunes 3 de mayo en incluso en un panel
muy interesante justamente sobre eso
sobre cómo podemos aumentar la
transparencia de las empresas de
internet
la transparencia sí perdón si no no lo
escuchó
no decía ya esta transparencia es el
medio del camino entre una posición de
no hacer nada o una posición de tener
una regulación extrema que puede tener
un como efecto dañino afectaciones que
no deseamos a nuestra libertad de
expresión entonces de esta transparencia
tiene que tener como resultado una mejor
rendición de cuentas por estas empresas
de internet pero al mismo tiempo
protegiendo nuestra libertad de
expresión también van a sacar un estudio
un estudio global sobre la violencia en
línea contra las mujeres periodistas
cuéntanos un poco sobre lo que vamos a
encontrar lo que ustedes encontraron
también
este estudio es un estudio realmente
amplio hemos entrevistado a 900
periodistas de 125 países y allí
descubrimos algunos datos alarmantes por
ejemplo 73% de estos periodistas
entrevistadas sufrieron algún tipo de
violencia en línea y de éstas se acercan
cercano a un tercio tuvieron algunos
impactos importantes o decidieron
autocensurarse o decidieron o tuvieron
problemas por ejemplo de salud mental
entonces los oyentes pueden encontrar el
estudio completo en la página de la
unesco con todas las características de
esta desde cosa terrible que es
violencia en línea contra mujeres
periodistas y leerme gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz resto
de ustedes también gracias por siempre
acompañarnos siga con nosotros
[Música]